Taylor Swift chose to alter the scene in  her music video where she is standing on  a scale that reads fat to her just  simply staring at her disruptive and  disapproving doppelganger this actually  strikes me as not just a word being used  in a context by one person where another  person says well in our culture that's  offensive this is a woman talking about  her own personal history revealing  something that is painful about herself  and exploring that through her art and  the idea that she is going to be scolded  and made to change her work because  other people didn't like the way that  she was negotiating her own pain in her  artwork that just strikes me as wildly  inappropriate there's a sense now that  maybe nothing is permanent art isn't  going to be permanent anymore so if  something and it becomes offensive well  we don't have to reckon with that as an  artifact of an earlier time anymore now  we can just go in and change it  foreign